Eine Rasenfunk-Sonderausgabe. Extrablatt, extrablatt. Der Frank und ich, der Max, wir haben euch etwas zu sagen. Jetzt in dieser ganz speziellen Rasenfunk-Folge. Mein Gott, sind wir aufgeregt. Ihr hofft nicht auch, es geht jetzt los. Frank, kannst du dich noch auf dem Sitz halten? Es ist so warm.
Servus, Max.
Servus, Frank. Schön, dass wir mal wieder miteinander sprechen. Wir hoffen, dass diese Folge auch Hörer hören, die uns vielleicht bisher noch gar nicht kannten. Deswegen, Frank, lieber Frank, sag mir doch mal, wer bist denn du eigentlich?
Ich bin der Frank Helmstadt. Man kennt mich vielleicht von Twitter als Ed Helmi oder von diversen anderen sozialen Netzwerken, meistens mit dem gleichen Namen. Und von einer oder zwei Rasenfunk-Ausgaben.
Ja, Tribünengespräche. Es sind dieselben Tribünengespräche.
Ja, und die ganz frühen Schlusskonferenzen. Nicht zu vergessen.
Ja, unglaublich.
Mit meiner großen Rolle als Ansager.
Das waren Zeiten, wo wir uns noch an Moderationen geschrieben haben.
Damals, 2014.
Also, wir machen zusammen den Rasenfunk. Ich bin der Max, Max Ackof-Ost, Ed Gehnetzer bei Twitter. Meine Stimme habt ihr eventuell schon mal gehört, weil ich eigentlich – nee, ich habe ja tatsächlich alle Sendungen moderiert und manchmal war eben noch der Frank mit dabei. Du bist immer hinter den Kulissen tätig.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Genau, und wir machen zusammen den Rasenfunk. Das ist das, was ihr gerade hört. Und wir haben damit 2014 angefangen und inzwischen stehen wir bei drei verschiedenen Formaten, die man hören kann. Auch die stellen wir jetzt noch mal vor, was paradox ist, weil mindestens ein Format kennt ihr, weil ihr in den Feed jetzt gerade reinhört. Aber es soll ja so ein bisschen eine Vorstellung unseres Projekts werden. Zum einen haben wir da die Schlusskonferenz. Frank, magst du da was zu sagen?
Klar, unser erstes Kind sozusagen und der Anfang allen Übels, darf man sagen. Genau, gar nicht eigentlich. Ja, der Anfang eigentlich eines tollen Projekts, glaube ich, wie man heute tatsächlich sagen kann. Die Schlusskonferenz ist unser Bundesliga-Rückblick, der immer am Ende oder kurz nach eines Bundesligaspieltags kommt und auf das vergangene Wochenende, den vergangenen Spieltag zurückblickt. In der Regel mit zwei Gästen. Anfangs waren es manchmal mehr und es gab auch mal Zuschaltungen, aber so in aller Regel sind es zwei Gäste. Meistens Journalisten oder Blogger. Genau, wo der liebe Max dann mit den Gästen über den Bundesligaspieltag spricht und wo er auch den Fokus auf die möglichst fußballlastig, wenig Boulevardesk, wenig Geschichten drumrum legt.
Genau, also hat sich so als Bundesliga-Format etabliert. Grundsätzlich könnten wir auf jedes Spiel zurückgucken. Also jetzt zur EM zum Beispiel, habt ihr vielleicht auch schon Folgen von uns gehört. Zu allen deutschen Spielen haben wir extra eigene Schlusskonferenzen gemacht. Und im Grunde versuchen wir einfach nur über Fußball so zu sprechen, wie wir zwei das gerne hätten. Nämlich, also Boulevard interessiert uns beide ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich. Und uns interessiert auch nicht so wirklich die Quote in dem Sinne, dass wir jetzt immer mit einem 30 Minuten Bayern-Blog einsteigen und mit dann 20 Minuten Dortmund und dann redet man noch fünf Minuten mit unserem Gast über die Eintracht aus Frankfurt. Genauso ist der Rasenfunk nicht. Und so ist auch die Schlusskonferenz nicht.
Genau. Aber kannst du dich vielleicht erinnern, der Rasenfunk hatte ursprünglich mal die Länge eines Fußballspiels, nämlich 90 Minuten ungefähr.
Das war ja immer mein Ziel, Frank.
Das ist auch länger her. Das war dein Ziel und du warst auch derjenige, der es irgendwann dann gebrochen hat, quasi für immer.
Ja, mit deinem Segen, aber muss man dazu sagen. Du hast immer gesagt, lass dir noch mehr Zeit. Ja, wir wollten immer zwischen 60, also ich wollte immer zwischen 60 und 90 Minuten machen. Du hast schon am Anfang gesagt, wenn das drei Stunden dauert, dauert das drei Stunden, nimm dir deine Zeit. Ja, das kam dann so ein bisschen dadurch, dass dann die Klagen immer lauter wurden. Wir legen pro Schlusskonferenz, liebe Hörer, legen wir meistens einen Schwerpunkt auf mindestens einen Verein und holen uns dazu auch einen Experten. Und dann im Laufe einer Saison wird da auch wirklich jeder Verein mindestens einmal ausführlich besprochen. Da achte ich sehr drauf. Und die Fans anderer Vereine haben sich dann oft beschwert, wenn ihr Segment, also ihr Spiel nur in fünf Minuten abgehandelt wurde. Deswegen sind wir inzwischen bei einem Zehn-Minuten-Schnitt angelangt. Und so wurde das immer länger. Naja, aber wir haben ja nicht nur die Schlusskonferenz, wir haben ja jetzt auch ein kurzes Format. Den Kurzpass, den haben wir zu EM eingeführt.
Ich habe schon vermutet, du meinst das Tribünengespräch mit dem kurzen Format. Genau, der Kurzpass kam zu EM. Kurz ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen relativ, aber in der Regel sollten es eigentlich nie so viel mehr als 30 Minuten werden.
Also für uns ist es sehr oft.
Genau, manchmal sind es auch nur 20 Minuten. Das Ziel war ja eigentlich, die Europameisterschaft ist ja jetzt der Start für den Kurzpass, aber das Ziel war ja auch so ein bisschen, die Fußballthemen völlig unabhängig von unseren beiden Formaten mal kurzfristig aufnehmen zu können, die man für wichtig hält und vielleicht mit einem Gast eben in wirklich einem kompakten Zeitformat besprechen zu können, mit wenig notwendiger Vorbereitung und wenig Nacharbeit, um einfach auch den zeitlichen Aufwand ein bisschen im Rahmen zu halten. Da kommen wir ja gleich noch drauf auf das Thema zeitlicher Aufwand. Und ich finde, das ist voll aufgegangen. Also ich bin als Höre, der ich ja natürlich auch bin, total begeistert von diesem Kurzpass, speziell zur EM jetzt. Das ist die täglich notwendige Fußballdosis.
Du willst mir damit ein Kompliment machen, was auch total nett ist. Ich glaube, nach außen wirkt es aber, als würden wir uns sehr, sehr selbstverliebt auf die Schultern klopfen. Also freut mich, dass es dir gefällt.
Da bin ich total selbstverliebt, weil ich bin da ehrlich begeistert.
Mir ist es gerade ein bisschen unangenehm. Aber es gibt jetzt den Kurzpass. Mal gucken, wie der sich weiterentwickelt. Und einer der Gründe, warum im Rasenfunk eine Sendung, die zwischen 30 und 45 Minuten lang ist, als kurz bezeichnet wird und niemand lacht. Ich würde sagen, der Grund dafür ist das Tribünengespräch, denn da nehmen wir uns mal so richtig Zeit. Genau. Da gibt es bisher die wenigsten Ausgaben, hängt aber wesentlich tatsächlich auch mit den Produktionsbedingungen zusammen. Also wir nehmen uns da viel Zeit für ein Thema. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine Sendung gemacht zu Doping im Fußball, die war glaube ich vier Stunden lang. Wir haben eine Sendung gemacht zu Taktik-Geschichte, die war fünf Stunden und 40 Minuten lang. Und jetzt haben wir die aktuellste Folge, ist eine Sendung zu den Fußball-TV-Rechten, wie sich das eigentlich alles entwickelt hat, dass man dafür solche Fantasiesummen inzwischen zahlt. Die hat glaube ich vier Stunden oder so was gedauert. Und das ist quasi die Spanne, in der wir uns bewegen im Rasenfunk, liebe Hörer. Es geht vom Kurzpass, vom Halbstunden-Format über die Schlusskonferenz, meistens so zwei Stunden. Nehmen wir mal den Rasenfunk-Royal aus. Bisschen zum Tribünengespräch, wo wir uns einfach kein Limit setzen lassen. Wobei ich gelernt habe, es gibt ein technisches Limit von sechs Stunden, aber das braucht die Hörer nicht interessieren. Ja, das sind unsere drei Formate, Frank.
Genau, vielleicht sollten wir an der Stelle gleich nochmal erwähnen für jemand, der jetzt zuhört und das vielleicht irgendwie über irgendeinem anderen, auf irgendeinem anderen Weg zu hören bekommt. Alle Infos, alle Sendungen, alle Links zum Abonnieren, alle sonstig nötigen Daten gibt es auf rasenfunk.de. Im Menü oben unter Sendungen gibt es die Links zu den einzelnen Sendungen und ansonsten ist die Seite auch voll mit ein paar Infos und auch mit jeder Menge Links zu anderen Fußball-Podcasts, wenn ihr da einfach mal einen Überblick bekommen wollt. Viele, viele sehr gute Formate und Sendungen dabei. Hört euch da einfach mal durch, die Podcast-Szene braucht vor allem Hörer.
Absolut, genau. Macht das unbedingt. Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon beim einen oder anderen rein gehört. So, aber jetzt haben wir ja ein Anliegen. Hörer, die uns kennen, die werden sich bis hierhin kolossal gelangweilt haben. Es tut uns sehr leid.
Und hören hoffentlich immer noch zu.
Na klar, die sind noch nicht mal warm geworden. Da ist noch nicht mal eine 1-2-Stunden-Anzahl. Ich glaube, unsere Jahre werden erst ab zwei Stunden so richtig aufmerksam.
Das ist deine volle Absicht, den eigentlichen Inhalt jetzt erst mal irgendwann ab der 15. Minute losbeginnen zu lassen, damit die Aufmerksamkeit auch voll da ist.
Nein, also wir haben jetzt eben diese drei Formate. Das ist quasi wie Sendungen oder wie Sendungsformate. Und die einzelnen Episoden, da haben wir jetzt inzwischen über 100 gemacht und über 200 Stunden Rasenfunk damit produziert. Ich führe da so ein kleines Spreadsheet und bin immer ganz erstaunt, welche Gesamtsumme da dann steht. Das heißt, wir haben da jetzt viel Zeit reingesteckt seit 2014 eben. Mehr auch, glaube ich, als wir beide uns hätten träumen lassen.
Hat sich sehr positiv entwickelt alles.
Und dann stellt sich die Frage, wann machen wir das? Antwort einfach in unserer Freizeit. Also es ist ein Hobbyprojekt. Und das ist jetzt allerdings dann auch der Grund, warum es diese Sendung gibt. Denn an der Situation wollen wir etwas verändern, Frank.
Ja, da wollen wir was verändern. Und das quält uns ja, wenn wir ehrlich sind, auch schon eine ganze Weile. Und verschiedene Optionen hat man sich dann natürlich durchgedacht. Der Punkt ist ganz einfach. Es hat sich halt gezeigt, dass vor allem bei Max, aber auch bei mir beim Projekt insgesamt der Aufwand halt tatsächlich groß geworden ist. Und das Problem, Max, ich glaube, du kannst es noch viel klarer sagen, weil du ja noch viel mehr durch die Sendung, durch die Aufnahme, Zeiten an Termine gebunden bist mit der ganzen Sache. Es ist halt einfach, dass man irgendwie versuchen muss, den Job und dieses Hobby Rasenfunk unter einen Hut zu bekommen. Und da wird es halt immer schwieriger, da die Zeit freizuschaufeln.
Wir sind beide Selbstständige. Das heißt, wir haben zwar weitgehende Macht über unseren Terminkalender. Ich glaube nur, deswegen hat der Rasenfunk bis hierhin überlebt. Aber tatsächlich ist eben die Situation so. Der Zeitaufwand ist immens und wird derzeit von unserer Freizeit abgefangen. Und wir würden jetzt gerne irgendwie in eine Situation kommen, in der wir ein bisschen was von der Rasenfunkzeit auch in die Slots reinpressen können, wo wir eigentlich berufliche Termine haben. Aber das geht natürlich nicht. Wir müssen ja beide unser Leben finanzieren und das unserer Angehörigen. Das geht eben nicht in dem jetzigen Setup, wo wir eigentlich nur laufende Kosten haben, nämlich für die Server. Wobei, da es deine sind, fangen wir die quasi indirekt ab. Aber wir haben ja auch schon viel in Technik gesteckt. Mehrere hundert Euro sind da bestimmt auch schon zusammengekommen. Ich will es mir eigentlich, glaube ich, gar nicht zusammenrechnen. Ich habe sogar schon Headset für Gäste gekauft, die oft mit dabei sind und durch die Republik geschickt. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt schon laufende Kosten und wir würden eben gerne versuchen, ob man mit eurer Hilfe, liebe Hörer, den Rasenfunk auf finanzielle Beine stellen kann.
Also solche, die uns weiterhin die Unabhängigkeit geben, um weiterhin das machen zu können, was wir für richtig halten für den Rasenfunk. Weil wir uns dazu entschlossen haben, zumindest für alles, was sich bisher geboten hat, nicht irgendwie in eine Werbefinanzierung zu gehen. Und darum wollen wir halt versuchen, das mit unseren Hörern, mit euch zusammen hinzubekommen. Und haben uns dafür unter anderem hauptsächlich für den Weg über patreon.com entschieden.
Patreon, also buchstabiert P-A-T-R-E-O-N. Dass ich als Franke das überhaupt buchstabieren kann, ist ein Wahnsinn. Da muss ich mich sehr konzentrieren. Patreon ist eine Plattform, die im Grunde genau für solche Leute wie Frank und mich und den Rasenfunk gemacht ist. Das heißt, hier kann man über regelmäßige Zahlungen Projekte unterstützen. Und es gibt eben die zwei Seiten. Es gibt zum einen diejenigen, die etwas produzieren und dafür gerne Unterstützung hätten von einer großen Community. Also es ist ein Bereich des Crowdfundings, würde ich sagen. Und es gibt dann eben diese Community, die Hörer, die Konsumenten eines Produkts, in unserem Fall eben Hörer, die etwas zurückgeben möchten für das, was sie auf die Ohren serviert bekommen. Und das geht über regelmäßige Zahlungen, wird abgewickelt über Paypal. Und auch wir wollen jetzt den Weg gehen, so wie einige andere Podcasts und unter anderem uns bei Patreon unterstützen lassen. Und dafür gründen wir – eigentlich ist das ja gerade schon wieder eine Gründungssendung, Frank fällt mir gerade an – wir gründen den RSC, den Rasenfunk Supporters Club.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Wir ziehen das jetzt einfach auf, als wären wir ein Verein, dem man beitreten kann. Na gut, ganz so ziehen wir es nicht auf. Ich würde mal sagen, von der Entscheidungsfindung her ist es eher RB Leipzig als United of Manchester. Genau, wir gründen den Rasenfunk Supporters Club und dem könnt ihr beitreten, wenn ihr euch dazu entscheidet, uns zu unterstützen. Bevor wir dazu kommen, wie man das alles machen kann, vielleicht gleich die wichtigste Frage, werden wir exklusive Inhalte machen? Das heißt, gibt es jetzt dann Sendungen, die nur Unterstützer hören können, Frank?
Nee, die wird es nicht geben. Tatsächlich wollen wir keine Zweiklassengesellschaft. Die Unterstützung soll freiwillig sein und völlig optional natürlich wird es ein paar Goodies geben. Die könnt ihr euch dann auf der Patreon-Seite angucken, die so ein bisschen davon abhängig sind, wie großzügig ihr uns unterstützen wollt. Aber tatsächlich wird es keine exklusiven Inhalte geben. Jeder wird in Zukunft auch weiterhin den Rasenfunk – alle Sendungen davon – hören können, ohne irgendwie dafür zu bezahlen.
Genau, das war uns eben ganz wichtig, dass quasi am Produkt auch letztendlich nichts verändert wird, denn wir machen es ja nicht für die Kohle. Das ist ja jetzt nur so eine Entwicklung, dass der Zeitaufwand immer krasser wird und wir auch wirklich noch mehr verliebt in unser gemeinsames Podcastbaby sind, glaube ich, jetzt über die Jahre. Ist ja auch so der Klassiker. Jetzt hat es gelernt zu laufen. Das sind jetzt fast zwei Jahre. Da wird es ja auch echt interessant mit Kindern. Ihr könnt euch auf patreon.com anschauen, was es für monatliche Möglichkeiten gibt, uns zu unterstützen. Letztlich geht das dann nach Summe, die es bereit seid, zu zahlen. Und da von uns beiden der ausdrückliche Hinweis, wir freuen uns – also das ist immer so ein doofes Spruch – aber wir freuen uns wirklich über jeden einzelnen Euro. Das heißt, niemand erwartet, dass ihr jetzt hier dasselbe zahlt wie für Netflix oder Amazon Prime oder was auch immer. Ihr könnt das natürlich gerne tun. Wir feiern euch dafür sehr und auch hart. Aber auch ganz kleine Beträge, da läppert sich was zusammen. Und ich muss sagen, mir wäre das sogar fast lieber. Denn ich finde das sehr sympathisch, dass es bei vielen anderen Podcasts so klappt, dass es da eine ganz, ganz große Basis gibt, die einfach nur ein Dollar im Monat gibt oder zwei Dollar im Monat. Und das finde ich irgendwie, ja, mir gefällt der Gedanke.
Genau. Apropos Dollar, nicht erschrecken, wenn da Dollar statt Euro auftauchen auf patreon.com, liegt einfach daran, dass es eine US-basierte Plattform ist und sich das da nicht weiter einstellen lässt, soll da bei euch tatsächlich nicht weiter irritieren. Wer übrigens nicht bei PayPal ist und da auch nicht hin möchte und das lieber auch anders machen möchte, für den steht es auf unserer Website, auf der es übrigens auch den Link zu Patreon nochmal gibt. Ich glaube, wir wissen noch gar nicht, wie der Menüpunkt heißen wird.
Das habe ich mir gerade gedacht.
Gut, wir sind sehr gut vorbereitet.
Ja, ja, das zeichnet den Rasenfunk auch aus.
Genau, davon leben wir. Wir werden tatsächlich, denke ich, irgendeinen Weg finden, um auf der Startseite auffällig einen Link zu platzieren auf die Unterstützungsseite. Dort wird es dann auch eine Kontonummer geben, eine dieser modernen, gut abzutippenden I-Bahn-Nummern. Und da könnt ihr uns dann auf ganz einfachem Weg ohne Gebühren und ohne Anmeldung bei irgendeinem Dienst einfach Geld zukommen lassen, wenn ihr das so lieber haben wollt. Genau.
Genau, das muss man vielleicht noch ganz kurz nämlich dazu sagen. Patreon nimmt sich fünf Prozent plus es gibt noch so ein paar Buchungsgebühren von dem, was wir bekommen. Das heißt, es kommt bei einem Euro, den ihr uns gebt, kommt nicht der komplette Euro bei uns an. Es wird jetzt allerdings auch nicht ein Riesenkuchenstück davon abgeschnitten. Das ist bei der Überweisung anders.
Ich glaube, ich muss dich korrigieren. Bei Patreon bezahlt tatsächlich der Spender die Gebühren. Also, wenn ihr einen Dollar bezahlt, dann kommt, wenn ihr den Dollar-Reward auswählt, dann bekommt hinterher angezeigt 1, 20 Dollar oder keine Ahnung genau, wie viel es jetzt sind. Aber es gehen tatsächlich die Gebühren mit zusätzlich. Wax wird euch natürlich vorher angezeigt, aber das mal als Hinweis. Ich weiß es deshalb, weil ich selber ein paar Projekte bei Patreon unterstütze, und da ist es immer so. Ich glaube, dafür gibt es auch keine Anstimmöglichkeiten.
Ja, da stimmt. Da hast du vollkommen recht, wie immer, Frank. So, sollen wir noch kurz sagen?
Irgendjemand muss ja hier für die Fakten zuständig sein.
Liebe Hörer, vielleicht beenden wir das mit dem Rasenfunk auch einfach. Wir haben uns auseinandergelebt.
Das hat sich lange abgezeichnet.
Ich behalte den Funk, du darfst den Rasen haben.
War ja klar. Jede Woche Rasen mähen.
Ja, ich habe den Funk. Also, es gibt den Rasenfunk-Supporters Club. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen auf zwei Wege, entweder bei patreon.com. Da könnt ihr entweder den Link direkt auf unserer Homepage anklicken oder auch mal dort nach Rasenfunk suchen. Man wird uns finden oder ihr könnt uns überweisen. Jetzt die Frage, Frank, was machen wir mit der Kohle, außer dass wir sie verprassen?
Na ja, also natürlich, wir haben das ja vorhin schon gesagt, die Hardware Investitionen gab es zum Teil jetzt schon, aber da stehen tatsächlich auch noch ein paar an. Wir wollen uns gerne ein Setup für mobile Aufnahmen zulegen, um das ein oder andere Tribünengespräch vielleicht mal face to face irgendwo in Deutschland machen zu können. Dann die Serverkosten wollen wir natürlich irgendwann vielleicht mal refinanziert bekommen. Das wäre so ein Ziel. Da wird sich hoffentlich auch noch viel tun. Die Kosten werden da hoffentlich steigen, hoffentlich im Sinne von, weil die Hörer steigen. Ja, und dann geht es halt schlichtweg auch darum, wir haben das ja vorhin angesprochen, sich die Möglichkeit zu schaffen, etwas vielleicht den ein oder anderen Job, das erwähnt, wir sind beide selbstständig, mal beiseite legen zu können und die Zeit lieber in den Rasenfunk zu investieren. Beziehungsweise das, was wir jetzt so an Zeitkredit schon genommen haben, damit irgendwie auszugleichen, das ist, glaube ich, so ein wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, ich finde, das sind sogar schon die wichtigsten Punkte. Vielleicht stellt sich noch so ein bisschen für manche die Frage, nicht jeder hat jetzt einen Euro locker, das ist auch mehr als verständlich. Wie kann man uns noch ohne Geld unterstützen, Frank?
Werbung, Werbung, Werbung. Sagt es weiter, erzählt euren Freunden vom Rasenfunk, postet es bei Twitter, bei Facebook, bewertet uns bei iTunes, verlinkt uns auf eurer Lieblingswebsite oder auf eurer eigenen. Egal, wenn andere davon erfahren, es ist uns sehr, sehr, sehr geholfen.
Genau, da freuen wir uns sehr drüber, auch weil wir ja auch immer versuchen, die Hörer auch mit einzubinden. Es gibt ein Forum mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Da nehmen wir auch gerne Fragen von euch in unsere Sendung mit rein. Das gibt es jetzt ja auch so jetzt nicht überall. Und auch da freuen wir uns auch einfach, wenn wir bekannter werden, wird auch automatisch das Forum noch bekannter und wir bekommen noch mehr Input für unsere Sendung. Das ist einfach eine schöne Sache. Und vielleicht bringt er ja auch damit Leuten das Format Podcast generell ans Ohr. Könnt ihr ihn ans Ohr legen und dann entdecken die Leute nicht nur, dass es den Rasenfunk gibt, sondern dass es noch ganz viele andere tolle Podcasts gibt. Die haben wir ja auch schon angesprochen, rasenfunk.de. Es gibt so viele Menschen, die genauso wie wir sehr viel Zeit in ihre Podcasts stecken. Und es wäre doch schön, wenn die alle noch ein paar Hörer mehr bekämen.
Genau. Vor allem ist ein wichtiger Punkt, glaube ich, diejenigen, die auch so ein bisschen technisch versiert sind unter euch, oder überhaupt Podcasts interessiert, können gerne auch so ein bisschen Botschafter spielen, weil ein Problem ist bei Podcasts mit Sicherheit, dass viele, die bisher nicht damit in Berührung waren, gar nicht so richtig wissen, was es ist, wie es funktioniert. Und eigentlich kann es ganz einfach sein, ein Smartphone hat fast jeder, die passenden Apps gibt es überall. Ja, sprecht einfach mit anderen drüber, sagt es ihnen weiter und bringt ein paar Leute zum Rasenfunk. Damit ist uns sehr, sehr geholfen.
Genau. Und damit auch hoffentlich auch zu anderen Podcasts. Und es kann ja so einfach sein. Es muss ja auch nicht mehr über das Smartphone laufen. Ich kenne auch ein paar Late Adopter, sage ich jetzt mal. Und Grüße damit unter anderem meine Eltern. Die habe ich einfach für die Newsletter angemeldet und die hören sich das ganz schnöde im Browser an. Da ist dann das Smartphone gar nicht so wirklich involviert. Das geht ja auch alles. Und wir sind ja sogar auch bei YouTube. Wir könnten ja sogar die 14-Jährigen abfangen. Frank, mein Gott, sind wir breit aufgestellt. Wann machen wir Rasenfunk Snapchat? Ich sage einfach mal, wenn wir 1000 Euro im Monat erreicht haben, dann machen wir das. Ja, Frank, müssen wir noch irgendetwas aufklären? Ich hoffe, dass wir verständlich das allen Leuten nahegelegt haben, ohne zu sehr zu langweilen.
Ich glaube, wir können ja wie immer sagen – und tatsächlich ist es ja so – wir sind auf allen Kanälen verfügbar, wenn ihr Fragen habt, Kritik daran. Immer her damit, mitmachen.rasenfunk.de wäre jetzt so das Forum, aber gerne auch bei Twitter, at Rasenfunk, oder auch at Helmi oder at Genetzer, direkt an uns beide. Wenn ihr wollt, ihr könnt uns über die Website, da gibt es ein Kontaktformular, schreibt uns eine Mail, wenn ihr das lieber privat klären wollt oder wenn ihr irgendwie einen anderen Weg habt, wo ihr sagt, da würden wir gerne unterstützen, aber war jetzt nicht im Angebot. Immer her mit dem Vorschlag, wir haben für alles ein offenes Ohr. Meldet euch einfach.
Und an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal der Hinweis, oder beziehungsweise nicht der Hinweis. Wenn wir jetzt die ganze Zeit über Unterstützung kriegen, dann sollten wir auch all denjenigen danken, die genau das schon die ganzen letzten zwei Jahre gemacht haben. Da freuen wir uns sehr drüber. Wir freuen uns über jeden Tweet. Ich hoffe, das merkt man auch daran, wie schnell wir reagieren und dass wir reagieren. Wir freuen uns über jeden Facebook-Like. Wir wissen auch, dass ganz viele von euch da draußen schon kleine Rasenfunk-Botschafter geworden sind. Das ist auch echt toll. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass uns das erst hierher gebracht hat. Dass wir jetzt überhaupt das Gefühl haben, eine Reichweite zu haben, wo man sowas mit Crowdfunding auch mal angehen kann. Nein, solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball. Wir sollten da von T-Shirts machen, solche Geschichten erzählt nur der Rasenfunk. Das wird dann vielleicht, naja. Wir lassen uns immer mal wieder was einfallen, mit dem wir dann euch auch vielleicht was zurückgeben können. Gut, Frank, ich glaube... Wir haben alle wichtigen Sachen angesprochen. Liebe Neuhörer und liebe Bestandshörer, danke, danke, danke, dass ihr bis hierhin mitgehört habt. Danke auch an der Stelle an alle Gäste, denn die machen den Rasenfunk erst möglich. Und danke auch dir, lieber Frank, dass ich dich mal wieder am Mikro hatte.
Danke, dass ich dabei sein durfte.
Ach, mein Gott. Es ist wie in einer perfekten Ehe. Aber so soll es ja auch sein. Wir lassen es doch nicht scheiden, würde ich sagen. Liebe Hörer, wir freuen uns über die Unterstützung. Geht auf rasenfunk.de. Danke euch.